man yeah I have a flaw I'll spank in
your Slenderman
okay well Oh what the [ __ ] are you doing
what are you doing nothing never get out
of there buddy
nothing just minding my own where did he
go oh no he'll be slim there that looks
fun seems to be doors opening behind you
pubes
that's so weird I'll shut what am i
doing in here stop opening the door you
can open them all invisible that's
awesome haha
but they play hey why don't you do it
come down into pole with me watching
stops pushing I say don't think I know
what you do my [ __ ] fights well what's
going on here
why do you the [ __ ] creep on me when I'm
taking a bad cheese slenderman how about
some privacy here you can do splat who's
by splashing why is it splashing there
the amnesia monster - done splashing
water please well you get him now that's
you creepy man don't you can go revisit
ball and stand matter
stop the [ __ ] door
you son of a [ __ ] so it looks like
Felix is all alone no Artie van right
there no you guys want a party uh I got
boxes boxes a1c and oh no it's shaking I
know I shouldn't on drugs
they always warned me are you huh no
what did I do
what's wrong doing that [ __ ] stop
shaking please you know that that card
is lame I'm gonna go to this ha ha ha
this we talking about is the best car
ever he's in the party oh you're not
allowed to mean I guess I better go down
in this creepy basement all alone
without all defenseless and I seen
anybody where are you people I see a
dead girl L mean I look very dead what
that one ha ha I shall probably oh hey
hey hold me
ok I would if you weren't such a skinny
little [ __ ] where is he oh hey let's go
uh-oh
I heard something wait is that him no
you know what we should just chill on
the couch whatever whoa what is going on
what is happening I'm looking at you
while I'm looking at you uh what is
going on
I actually scare me go Slenderman you
idiot he's got him finally I passed out
he's finally dead body and he was like
hey guys you got now I got the best
angle ever here I can't move
it just says someone okay yeah she
passed out of my McLaury what is slender
man's greatest weakness bananas
well that's everyone's greatest weakness
let's get really accessible the other
way there's always one ethical ground
you can lose this dead girl oh I found a
note good pits she need to shave no it's
not me what's going on up here
nothing this is sweet as couch I need
you it's huh why would I turn around
when I'm looking forward to yeah yeah
yeah nothing just a big train of people
walking like a William no no I
follow me I'm spit can't see anything
yeah awesome candy no no okay now
counting okay I think I think we chase
him I mean oh no we did not we did not
chase anyone
you're talking about me man you good is
it my turn to be finder man yes what it
might be hey you said he was visible and
when you're invisible he can pass
through regular doors ow
I fell down the set how'd you fall
behind me I'm slender man I don't kind
of fall don't care happens in ER oh yes
Callaway yeah I don't understand please
what are you doing over there
there's a note you want some Chinese
food
wait what happened oh okay thank you
buddy this might killed over I think I
was a really bad idea
denne denne denne denne denne denne
denne denne dead dead dead dead
and again you get where you're going
oh please just take the box just take
the box that is a sweet box you're right
okay happen that's a fair trade I'll let
you go oh you [ __ ]
I hate any meats Gilly I do wanted the
box I swear right it's your the wops ID
okay we got game your sled you have five
seconds what Oh them bar besides before
I hate you
hi